anytime I deviated from that love and
went into something else I just was so
unhappy but even within the careers that
were pursuing we can train ourselves to
think like outsiders and help loosen up
the mind in the process I once counted
with a girlfriend that I had probably
over 80 jobs you have this like wealth
of information and knowledge and ability
to acquire skills that nobody a hundred
years ago 20 years ago could dream about
often what separates creative from
conventional thinkers is that they
simply search wider self-reliance is to
me the most you're going to develop
anything in life that that has to be it
that's the most important skill you need
to be able to put up with fools and
laugh at them and not take them
seriously life is inherently chaotic and
it doesn't fit into our tidy formulas
self transformation we think comes
through a spiritual journey therapy a
guru who tells us what to do when you
are motivated when you feel yourself
emotionally engaged in the subject you
learn faster he's an American author and
speaker known for his books on strategy
power and seduction
he has written five international
bestsellers his work has been featured
in New York Times and New Yorker CNN USA
Today and many more media publications
he's Robert Greene and here his top ten
rules for success the difference between
people who are successful and not
although those who are successful seem
to know from age of seven or eight maybe
older you know they're very in tune with
what they love they compared to a voice
inside their head not literally a voice
but something saying you you really are
drawn to this subject and they hear it
throughout their lives and for me it was
it was writing and books since I was a
kid and you know at anytime I deviated
from that love and went into something
else I just was so unhappy I knew that I
wasn't doing the right thing and so it's
just like this voice that keeps drawing
you back to what you really really
of some of the most important
discoveries inventions and innovations
cut within a field come from people who
are trained in a much different field
and who have an outsider's approach
Louis Pasteur was a classic example of
this he was trained as a chemist in
mineralogist so he brought amidst a much
different way of thinking to the subject
of medicine and germs a method that was
infinitely more creative Albert Einstein
was a complete outsider his two most
important discoveries came when he was
working at the Swiss Patent Office
Google itself exemplifies this idea it
is perhaps the most successful business
on the planet founded by two men who are
relatively complete outsiders to
business and who therefore structured
and directed their company in a very
novel and creative fashion I could go on
and on and on with this list including
many great artists there are two
important reasons why Outsiders
generally have a creative advantage
first they are less steeped in and
burdened by the conventions of the field
that they are attacking they ask a
different set of questions they approach
problems from unconventional angles and
second they are often trained in totally
unrelated fields and so can make
interesting and creative connections
between two very different forms of
thinking like science and business or
chemistry and medicine or engineering
and design now we can't all consciously
follow such a path but even within the
careers that were pursuing we can train
ourselves to think like outsiders and
help loosen up the mind in the process I
once counted with a girlfriend that I
had probably over 80 jobs you know I
like was a guide for Greek ruins when I
worked construction in Crete I taught
English in here and in Spain
um I did the first like encyclopedia for
the internet I helped write an
encyclopedia I was a busboy a waiter god
I'm not leaving out something juice oh I
was a Skip tracer I worked for a
detective agency helping find people who
left town you know without telling st.
where they were yeah you know with all
those things if you think about it helps
cuz it's like doing research for a book
or well think about being a writer is
that um you have interested people yeah
and life and so I'm always wanting to
know what it's like you know what it's
like to be Shira you know would you want
to know yeah I really would
cuz then if I really knew what that one
made Shira tick then Shira would become
a character in my next book mm yes so
you got to be curious about people and
having a lot of different jobs helped
out yeah
there's differences and then there's
there's not differences so you know the
brain is the same the brain evolved over
the course of millions of years so I try
to make the point that you know what da
Vinci was going through the process is
that there's a template there and it's
the same because our brains haven't
really changed in an evolutionary sense
in four or five hundred years on the
other hand the circumstances are
different and people now live in a world
where there's many more distractions so
it's harder to do that kind of focus
that I was mentioning so in some ways
it's a little bit harder and the people
that I've interviewed are really good at
shutting out all of the distractions of
the world that's sort of what separates
them every single one of them Paul
Graham you know Paul Graham Paul doesn't
have a smartphone you know he doesn't
spend time on the Internet
he's extremely focused the woman yoky
Matsuoka
she she does all of her writing with a
pen and paper she's not sitting there
day in and day out on the computer
checking her Facebook or Twitter page or
whatever I could go through all of them
that way Steve Jobs is sort of
the ultimate icon of mastery of our era
and he said the only thing that's
differentiated me from everyone else was
my level of focus I could take a problem
and I could focus on it and burrow into
it and everybody else was so distracted
he knew how to close his door get away
from his wife his kids everyone and just
focus so the all of these people have to
overcome the intense distractions in our
world they and they're able to do it on
the other hand what you can get with a
click on the internet with a Google
search compared to what da Vinci had to
do or a scientist in the 19th or 20th
century is absolutely astounding so what
you have at your fingertips the
knowledge the things that you can
connect and learn about the potential
for learning skills is out of this world
so if you're able to overcome the
distracting elements that are it's my go
over and I compare it to if you ever
watch a basketball game and you see the
opposing team shooting free throw and
everyone behind him and the stands are
all going like this with those big you
know trying to distract him there's like
hundreds of people that's what the world
is like now you've got thousands of
people waving those things you've got so
many distractions if you're able to
overcome that and be a person that can
focus you have this like wealth of
information and knowledge and ability to
acquire skills that nobody a hundred
years ago 20 years ago could dream about
use active imagination is deceptively
simple often what separates creative
from conventional thinkers is that they
simply search wider they use their minds
to generate possibilities that others
don't think of then they work to verify
what they came up with we saw a classic
example of this with posture another
great example is with Henry Ford early
on in his career in the earliest years
of what would later become the Ford
Motor Company
Ford was anxious to into speed up the
production of cars it was he saw the
automobile as the ultimate consumer
product but in order for it to become
that he had to greatly increase
production rate in his factory so he
spent a couple days looking at his
employees on the factory floor and
trying to imagine how he could get them
to move faster from car to car suddenly
one day he imagined something completely
different he imagined the men standing
still and the cars coming to them he
didn't know what that really meant but
he decided to try it out and lo and
behold it increased productivity by such
an incredible exponential rate that it
could now become the consumer product
that he envisioned things like
antibodies or assembly lines they seemed
so obvious to us now but they are never
obvious in the present and they involve
an incredible leap of what I call active
imagination the difference between
regular and active imagination is that
the latter is used consciously to reach
very very practical results it's not
imagination for coming up with wild
things its imagination used for very
practical results think of the active
imagination as a kind of creative muscle
that you're developing first within the
loose constraints of what you're working
on you open your mind up to you give a
complete free rein you entertain almost
every possibility that you could imagine
or visualize you engage in what Charles
Darwin calls fools experiment Foles
experiments this is the fun play part of
serious play you use notebooks sketches
diagrams models prototypes to help
externalize the products of your
imagination once you have gone through
this you now enter the second serious
part
of the process first you choose one or
few of the more promising possibilities
that were generated by your imagination
and now you actively work to test verify
or confirm it
this might entail launching a beta
version on the public once you have
feedback you now go back into the first
part of the process in a shortened form
using your imagination to perhaps take
what you have into an even better and
higher form circling constantly through
this process in shorter and shorter
cycles until you've got something that's
both incredibly imaginative and
incredibly realistic and practical by
developing this by going through this
over and over and over again you will
develop your imagination into an
incredibly powerful creative muscle what
really impressed me with someone like 50
is he grows up in a world without any
parents I mean it's a hard thing to
imagine in life but put tribe for a
moment put yourself in those shoes he
never knew his father to this day he
doesn't know whose father is his mother
was murdered when he was 8 years old
she was a hustler
his grandparents take him in but they
have nine other kids that they're
looking after from various different
extended families so he's basically has
no parental supervision from the age of
eight and even before then he had very
little and so he has to find and
discover everything for himself he can't
depend on other people to give him
anything they won't give him money they
won't give him clothing they won't give
him education and so he on his own as if
that metaphor being on a desert island
is his life he's on a desert island he
has to develop everything for himself
and he does and that is what has made
him a person of incredible power now he
doesn't feel dependent on anybody or
anything he knows that if anything goes
wrong in life he has the resources
within himself to find the right answer
and so I think this is an idea that
applies to an individual it applies to a
company to a leader to a CEO it applies
to relationships self-reliance is to me
the most you're going to develop
anything in life that that has to be it
that's the most important skill there's
a phrase in the Bible that's become kind
of an expression called suffer fools
gladly and somehow in our modern world
to cut totally inverted which is
something that it kind of bothers me the
original expression meant that you're
constantly surrounded
fools half the world are fools or
whatever the percentage is and and maybe
you're a bit of a fool and what you need
to do is you need to suck you need to be
able to put up with fools and laugh at
them and not take them seriously that's
what it means in the Bible and that's
the wisdom in the Bible and then somehow
it got turned around in modern times
where where it seems to be a virtue that
you don't suffer fools gladly that you
don't put up with them that you get
angry about them that you confront them
that you try to change them and on and
on and on and on and on and the idea
that I try to say it's part of my
chapter on social intelligence which is
I try and tell you that you're not going
to be a master in this world unless you
know how to get along with people we're
social animals you can't just be a nerd
a tech guy has no contact with people
you have to learn how to be with people
and be socially intelligent and it's
actually a beautiful form of
intelligence and one of the aspects is
to learn how to suffer fools gladly and
I tell you what I think a fool is a fool
is somebody that doesn't have the right
kind of sense of priorities in life they
magnify the little things that we should
just not worry about into some huge
dramatic thing and huge dramatic things
that completely ignore they have no
sense of proportion and we encounter
them every day in our lives and in fact
we encounter a little bit of them in
ourselves we all have a foolish side so
let's all be patient with fools if you
try and change them or fight them you're
only going to waste valuable time and
energy in your short life learn to laugh
at them learn to no it's part of the
human comedy I find that that's going to
save you energy in the end and I have
stories in there of how not only do you
suffer fools gladly but you turn it
around to an advantage so I have a story
in there Daniel
Everett who's a great kind of
anthropologist and linguist
and he came out with a radical new
theory on linguistics and suddenly he
finds himself being attacked by everyone
in the field but they're attacking him
in this ad hominem manner as if he's a
charlatan and they're not attacking his
ideas and it's driving him crazy and now
he's dealing with fools and he decides
that what he's going to do is he's going
to turn it to his advantage he's going
to make sure it out from now on that
anything he presents in a book or a
lecture is airtight they would usually
pinpoint one little small thing and
something he said that could be
inconsistent and say therefore your
whole theory is wrong okay from now on
I'm not going to be anything
inconsistent so he took the foolish
aspect of these attacks and he decided
he would make it would make him stronger
and would make his ideas stronger that's
what suffer fools gladly is about and I
have other examples there in the book
you learn to embrace uncertainty and
chaos life is inherently chaotic and it
doesn't fit into our tidy formulas not
only does this not make you anxious but
you find chaos and uncertainty deeply
exciting and stimulating slowly adopting
this as an overall philosophy will
naturally loosen the mind up and give it
greater creative flow you will naturally
consider more options and possibilities
the way to transform yourself is through
your work now I know this runs counter
to our prevailing cultural prejudices
work is too ugly too boring too banal
self-transformation we think comes
through a spiritual journey therapy a
guru who tells us what to do intense
group experiences and social experiences
and drugs but most of these are ways of
running away from ourselves and
relieving our chronic boredom they are
not connected to process and so any
changes that occur don't last instead
through our work we can actually connect
to who we are instead of running away
and by entering that slow organic
process we can actually change ourselves
from the inside out in a way that's very
real and very lasting this process
involves a journey of self-discovery
that can be seen as quite spiritual if
you like and in the end of this process
we contribute something unique and
meaningful to our culture through our
work which is hardly ugly boring or
banal I want you to get over this notion
that I find so annoying that so many
people have that success and power in
life is dependent on something like
genetics like some people are born with
a larger brain or they have wealthy
parents who are able to send them to the
right school or or it's a lot a matter
of luck what really makes people
successful and powerful in life and it's
not just me saying this I read hundreds
of books on the subject what makes
people successful is their degree of
motivation ok I could repeat it a
hundred times but it's true every time I
say it when you are motivated when you
feel yourself emotionally engaged in the
subject you learn faster you learn what
could take somebody 10 years to learn
you can learn in two years when you feel
emotionally engaged with something
you're able to push past off all the
obstacles the sense that it's genetics
or the size of our brain or our parents
money you can't control any of that
obviously and they could become kind of
crutches for some people but the amount
of motivation you feel the emotional
connection you have to what you're
studying or doing that is something
within your control that is something
you can choose to take and it is you're
going to find people giving you all
kinds of great advice about your careers
about where you should go of you know
for your MBA etc but if there's one
piece of advice that I think is more
important than that is that is it is
this idea of
following this these natural
inclinations and creating your own
career path and finding a way to engage
the deepest motivating parts of your
psyche thank you so much for watching I
made this video because Owen Forbes
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below I'll
see what I can do I'd also love to know
which of Robert Greene's top ten rules
have the biggest impact on you leave it
in the comments I'll join the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and we'll see you soon